[Music]
across the country from kellogg's cereal
plants in michigan to coal mines in
alabama union workers are on strike we
have to do what we have to do it's just
our lives this is our livelihood they're
demanding higher wages better benefits
and improved working conditions
speaking to workers and labor leaders in
different sectors of the economy what i
really heard was that there's a lot of
frustration among workers and even
distrust of their employers and so
you know these folks feel as though it
was revealed to them during the pandemic
that their employers aren't necessarily
looking out for their best interests and
that they need to advocate for
themselves and this is what
unions are really hoping to capitalize
on
meanwhile many non-union workers are
looking to collective action to improve
their conditions since the covet 19
pandemic began workers from across a
wide range of industries from trucking
to media to museums to higher ed to
bookstores are working to or have
successfully unionized their workplaces
so what's behind this new worker unrest
is it just a passing moment or is this
shift likely to last
before the pandemic labor unrest was on
the rise in 2018 and 2019 work stoppages
ticked upwards with 20 and 25
respectively but pre-pandemic american
labor was not in a position of strength
for decades now private sector union
membership numbers have been in decline
private sector workers were really
beaten down before the pandemic the
unionization numbers were low and they
weren't really striking in great numbers
and they weren't really winning
particularly strong contracts the
economic disruption brought on by the
coronavirus gave workers new leverage
data compiled by cornell university
found that the number of workers on
strike in 2021 increased steadily from
the beginning of the year
so far these actions have produced mixed
results workers at deer just this week
ratified a new six-year contract and
this brings to an end a strike that had
been ongoing for over a month it
involved more than ten thousand workers
at deer it was taking place at deer
where there hadn't been such labor
activity in 35 years and so this just
really speaks to the
i think the ground toll frustration that
we're seeing among american workers and
also the power
that unions feel that they have at this
point in time in a statement the uaw
wrote our members willingness to strike
in order to attain a better standard of
living and a more secure retirement
resulted in a groundbreaking contract
and sets a new standard for workers
in a statement to the wall street
journal dear chief executive john may
said we're giving employees the
opportunity to earn wages and benefits
that are the best in our industries we
have faith that in return our employees
will find new and better ways to improve
our competitiveness
unions built the middle class
unions put power in the hands of workers
despite an endorsement from the
president earlier this year a drive to
unionize an amazon warehouse in alabama
failed when workers overwhelmingly voted
against collective action two closely
watched upcoming unionization drives
include one in an amazon warehouse in
staten island and another at some
starbucks stores in buffalo new york
when employers are fighting unions they
will bombard workers with text messages
or in-app messages they'll also during
working hours require
the employees to listen to
anti-union messages about why they
shouldn't unionize where there's no law
requiring equal time workers interested
in creating a union form committees
dedicated to advancing unionization
oftentimes these committees lobby their
colleagues through personal advocacy but
committees also get their message out
with pro-union literature text messages
events and today social media campaigns
in november the company's ceo howard
schultz traveled to buffalo to make a
personal appeal to starbucks employees
we're not a perfect company
we're not perfect people
i'm not a perfect person
mistakes are made we learn from them and
we try and fix them i think if the
starbucks workers in buffalo are able to
win their union um in spite of the
massive massive anti-union onslaught
that they've received
that will that will be a promising sign
in an open letter to employees on its
website a starbucks executive wrote our
actions in buffalo are not about whether
we are pro-union or anti-union it's
quite simply that we are pro-starbucks
partners
as you know our heritage and culture are
built on the belief that by working
directly together as partners we can
build a different kind of company on
november 18th starbucks employees in
mesa arizona said they would like to
join a union
so is this wave of strikes a tipping
point for american labor and will we see
this unrest continue to pick up momentum
it's too early to tell
i think there are promising signs right
now
employers have the ability to fight off
unions whether organizing drives
or strikes with
greater resources and and more legal
support so it's it's very very difficult
to organize or to win a strike the
current strike wave is not large by
historical standards especially when
compared with the hundreds that occurred
annually in the 1960s and 70s critics of
unions warned that work stoppages and
efforts to influence labor policy could
push up prices for consumers and slow
production we live in a different world
than we did in 1950 there are dozens and
dozens of laws on the books that protect
employees there are safety and health
rules back in the day when the only
place a person had to go for protection
was a union contract or a union
grievance procedure
today an employee can pick up the phone
and call the eeoc or osha or the nlrb
but those in favor of expanded
unionization would dispute that
characterization it's a typical
anti-union talking point to say that
unions were good for a while but we
don't need them anymore but what we see
across the country is that workers that
don't have the protection of a union
contract can be fired
at any time for almost any reason this
is true of employment at will often
contracts state the workers can be fired
for good cause bad cause or no cause at
all in recent years some states like
michigan wisconsin west virginia and
kentucky have passed right-to-work laws
a right-to-work law gives workers the
freedom to choose whether or not to join
a labor union in the workplace these
laws also make it optional for employees
in unionized workplaces to pay for union
dues required for union representation
whether they are in the union or not
opponents of right-to-work laws say they
allow non-union members to benefit from
union representation and union-secured
benefits without sharing in the cost of
negotiating those benefits they argue
these non-due paying workers ultimately
lead to union membership decline
looking ahead both given and de bruges
said they would be paying close
attention to what happens with the
protecting the right to organize act or
pro act earlier this year the house
passed the legislation which supporters
say would make it easier for workers to
unionize opponents of the law argue that
it would undermine workers rights and
stifle business
after the proact was blocked in the
senate democrats added some of its
elements to the build back better act or
the budget reconciliation bill which
they are currently trying to get through
congress